foreign
before I bang the gavelen we start there
is quite a significance to this day in
history
you may remember the 2000 movie Miss
Congeniality an FBI agent Sandra Bullock
goes undercover in the Miss U.S pageant
as you know they try to ask serious
heavy questions of each of the
candidates for the crown and Miss Rhode
Island Cheryl Fraser was asked by The
Pageant MC to describe her perfect date
she said
April 25th because it's not too hot or
not too cold
so we are here on the perfect date
okay with that call to order
the children and family law committee
we're going to be hearing House Bill 253
sent To Us by
the other people
and one of those persons is Senator Dan
Ennis to present his bill senator
the other people
there's that was a compromise yes all
right well thank you for that uh Dan
Ennis uh from Bradford New Hampshire
representing District Seven and I'm
pleased to be here this morning
um with the August committee members and
the esteemed chair uh to introduce to
you Senate Bill uh 253 and this is a
relatively
um simple and straightforward bill and
if you look at the text of the bill
you'll see that it's really less than a
page and essentially what this bill does
is simply create a situation where if a
parent
requests the records of treatment for a
minor medical treatment that those need
to be released to the parent so you know
as I say it's extremely straightforward
it does have some Protections in there
in the event a physician or other health
caregiver has reason to believe that
such disclosures would put the child at
risk then that information can in fact
be withheld I'm happy to take any
questions you might have and I know
there are others who will be testifying
as well thank you
representative Raymond
uh thank you Mr chairman and thank you
so much senator for coming and sharing
your bill with us my question is on line
16 of your bill which is section c it
says when a healthcare provider has
determined by clear and convincing
evidence based upon articulable fact
that disclosure of Records to a parent
is likely to result in abuse or neglect
then they can take action my question is
how does this match with RSA 169 C 13
which says that the burden for dcyf so
abuse and neglect cases is a
preponderance of the evidence how do we
reconcile that this bill amongst other
bills we've seen this session
is asking people who are mandated
reporters to utilize a higher burden of
proof than what dcif would look at when
determining whether abuse or neglect is
likely to occur or have occurred
um I'm not sure I can answer that in a
way that would satisfy me
um so if I might
um
do you feel that a change in language in
this bill would be appropriate perhaps
through an amendment to bring it in line
with that RSA personally I personally
having worked in child welfare for my
entire career cannot support any bill
that uses clear and convincing when
referring to abuse and neglect okay so
that's my personal stance and I've been
very vocal in the well and hear about
that
um but I can't speak for the rest of so
would it be true that you're more
comfortable with articulable facts I'm
more comfortable with making sure that
any bill that we have doesn't undermine
our child protective statute because I
think that we have an obligation to the
children of our state I agree thank you
for the question
representative Moulton thank you Mr
chairman
um I'm just wondering how this would
translate into mental health where
that's that's kind of the most protected
portion of mental or sorry medical
records
um so I just don't know how this would
align well they're so carve out in the
bill for mental health so I think the
the the intent is that mental health
will be the same as physical health and
again information will be released to
the parent unless there is a reason to
believe the child would be at risk if
that information is released
so I mean mental health is a is a
medical sort of situation I I think
thank you
representative Bickford
thank you Mr chairman
um I'm trying to understand why we even
need this bill it's my understanding we
have a constitutional right for parents
to access uh Records period yes thank
you for that and I I anticipated
um that question and I I think when you
look at it you say well okay then why
not
um I think it's a statement that
reinforces what we all believe many of
us believe should be the case and that
is parents should have
open access to their child Children's
Medical Records so
um you know I I think it's a
reaffirmation and right now where we're
seeing information withheld in some
cases I think it makes sense to put this
into place
thank you
thank you Mr chairman I'm sorry I didn't
understand that oh it's like we do you
agree we do have a constitutional right
for access to records or
et cetera et cetera I believe that we do
I'm not sure it's being fully followed
in all cases
and this this I believe helps bring it
back to the fore and reinforces that
right
um follow up again
yes uh thank you Mr chairman follow-up
there's also
on line 12 you've you've jumped in with
a protective order yes and it looks like
it's kind of automatic and it seems like
excessive and extreme to me which would
not be I don't believe that that would
apply in a constitutional right
so
um it's like a conflict here by putting
these exceptions in
I see and that was the biggest one and I
do agree with
representative Raymond on the issue of
the uh healthcare provider it's a broad
very broad term it is and articulate
it's a very low uh threshold and then of
course you get clearance Adventure which
is much higher right so uh
anyway I I guess if you don't want to
answer that I understand I'm not sure I
know how to answer that okay but thank
you I appreciate the question thank you
Senate yes
um something from me I do know in this
committee people from both parties
um
will speak in favor if it's their thing
and against if it isn't on why do we put
something in law that's already in law
and I've heard some very cogent
arguments from both sides why it doesn't
hurt if it's already in law uh under one
of the carve outs we know that there are
certain federal exceptions
um you may not know I'm part-time CEO of
a medical and Counseling Center in
Kingston so I take these things up with
my staff and learn a lot and sometimes
that translates to what I'm doing here
yes and they have told me repeatedly of
the carve outs that are federal if a
person of tender age is a patient or a
client certain things are not shareable
that's federal law and to me the
parenthetical a uh simply just
underscores we believe that we will
follow that
I've also heard from my staff that they
like the the idea of articular bull
facts even if it's unpronounceable it's
a good idea because otherwise you can
get extremely subjective that's right
and while many people in the medical and
counseling profession are
you know as objective as they possibly
can be
um would you believe with me that there
were some who aren't I would believe
that be required to okay prove your case
you don't want this information passed
on is it because you have an agenda or
is it because you think there's good
reason if there's good reason you should
be able to articulate it absolutely yes
thank you is that your purpose of that
that is the purpose representative thank
you for clarifying welcome
and forgive me my allergies are awful
today so my that isn't quite where it
normally might be but thank you any
questions representative Moulton yes
thank you again Mr chairman uh another
source of concern that I have over this
is that they're
and this is a little bit
um
different than I than I The Stance I
normally take
um because I I have issues usually if
there's too much of a of a punishment
um but in this case I'm on the opposite
end of the spectrum where there's
there's no punishment and
unfortunately our law system
has a hard time preventing laws from
being broken and they're only punishing
laws after they're broken and by having
some type of punishment it can tend to
defer crime but we have a hard time
preventing crime yes so in this case if
there's so what coming together uh in
this case if there's no punishment
involved then there's no way to defer
this
um from being broken in other words on
line 18
there there has to be that they would
um
the health care would have to determine
that there would be abuse and neglect
correct but there's no way to really
know that so then if they're going and
disclosing all of this mental health all
these mental health issues
aren't they without knowing you got to
get into a question I am okay if there's
how how would we
if there's no way to know if there's
going to be abuse or neglect and no
punishment if they disclose something
then they're more likely to disclose
something
without you know without knowing what's
going to happen and that can put the
child at risk doesn't it
but there's also no penalty for
withholding that information if there is
articulable evidence that it might put
the child at risk so I think you can go
on both sides of that particular
question the intent of this bill wasn't
to put people in jail but rather to
emphasize that this is important to
parents and families and to provide a
little bit of guidance there
thank you for the question Senator to
follow up would it be the case that
perhaps
were this to be signed into law and we
start to notice uh breaches of this in
any direction the follow-up then can be
some enforcement mechanism it could be
but in the meantime isn't it the case
that this is simply stating our intent
this is what we want that's correct okay
and that is the intent of the bill
yes
yes okay any other questions
okay saying none thank you so much
Senator thank you and thank you all for
your time and consideration have fun
over in the other place okay
the chair recognizes that Jennifer Jones
office of the child advocate
Jen Jones
is it Jen or Jennifer or
welcome Jen to our place
in it you're only in trouble if you
don't turn the mic on
you're good good morning good morning
um Jen Jones or Jennifer if I'm in
trouble like I said
um nice to see you all this morning
thank you for having me Office of the
child advocate
um so we are here this morning in
opposition of SB 253
um and so while the office of the child
advocate absolutely recognizes the
importance for parental rights and
access to their child's health care
records
um
you know in an effort to be in the know
and to be able to safely parent their
child we also recognize flaws in this
bill that would put a child at risk one
of those flaws being
when you talk about a medical
professional or a health care provider
being able to recognize if abuse and or
neglect would be a risk factor in in
this bill it asks those providers to
make that judgment based on
um a preponderance of evidence and
that's a greater standard than we even
ask our investigators
um you know for example for a cpsw with
a division for children youth and
families
um they aren't even held to that
standard
and they are
able to access a totality of facts right
they they're tasked with an
investigation they're working with
Health Care law enforcement um Partners
in investigating
um
all aspects of the allegation and we're
asking that burden really to be put on
our Mental Health Providers our health
care providers when they don't have the
ability to to conduct such an
investigation to have those answers in
the Forefront and so I think in some of
that conversation has come up already
um you know in this room where it puts
our our children at risk and there are
protocols in place to ensure that Mental
Health Providers medical providers are
reporting concerns for abuse and or
neglect or
or um giving parents information that
they need to know or understand in an
effort to keep their kids safe and so
um you know I think this new uh ask is a
really really difficult one and it has
the you know the
possibility of really putting our
children at risk and
um I also want to touch on the fact that
um
asking this Loops in mental health and
so when we talk about
um parents being able to access their
children's mental health records that's
a really sacred relationship and I think
it runs the risk of
being able to be misused or
misrepresented and I think that's why
these
records are typically very difficult for
anyone to get a hold of
um you may see that play out where a
child May absolutely have disclosed
something may have happened to them
right but there's also co-occurring
mental health and that that may be used
to erode the child's credibility when in
fact both could be true
um and so I think
um
you know we we're very concerned that
mental health records are being looped
into this as well
thank you so much and I'm happy to
answer any questions
seeing none you came as genuinely as Jen
thank you very much well thank you glad
to know that
Dr Julie Kim I know you've got to get
back up north so
um I have a request that you get taken
uh soon on and here you are
thanks good morning I'm Dr Julie Kim I'm
here to testify as a pediatric
oncologist who's been practicing at
Dartmouth Health now for almost 18 years
in addition I'm the incoming president
for the New Hampshire chapter of the
American Academy of Pediatrics so I
represent the pediatricians across this
state
as pediatricians our commitment is first
and foremost to our patient providing a
safe space for communication is
essential to upholding the commitment
which is why I speak on behalf of many
who oppose Senate bill 253.
as a pediatric oncologist my patients
have life-threatening diagnoses when I
meet a new adolescent patient I assure
them that our conversations happen in a
safe space open communication with my
patient is imperative for me to manage
their chemotherapy and their side
effects my patients will become
immunocompromised from their
chemotherapy and their increased risk
for infections
I need to know if my teen patients are
sexually active so I can appropriately
screen them and treat their infections
before an infection becomes
life-threatening I need to know whether
my patient who is receiving chemotherapy
or radiation needs reproductive
counseling I also need to know if my
patient smokes Vapes drinks alcohol or
has a substance use disorder so we can
treat these as they may interact with
their treatments for that saves their
lives
some teens as you know don't want their
parents or Guardians to know these kinds
of details about them they're going to
kill me it's a common comment and while
I guarantee a safe space for discussions
with them that does not mean I block all
information to parents or Giver or
caregivers I and every pediatrician wish
every child had a nurturing caregiver
relationship and open communication with
those who love them we spend much of our
time promoting and celebrating healthy
parental involvement and communication
and we work with our developing
adolescents to teach them how to manage
their emotions and communicate more
effectively with their caregivers we
offer to be present and facilitate and
mediate discussions with them
the vast majority of the time this is
successful and my teen patients are able
to speak with their caregivers they can
process the news together support each
other and they all realize they have the
same goal as their child that my patient
everyone wants this patient to live the
healthiest life possible
however we still need to be mindful that
there are will there are exceptions and
there will always be exceptions I care
for a sexually active teenager with a
bone cancer and the first day that I met
her I diagnosed her with a sexually
transmitted infection she and her
parents already had a volatile
relationship her parents had a history
of domestic violence toward each other
and the parents had already sent my
patient away to live with other
relatives for short stints of time when
her behavior became difficult
she did not want her parents to know she
was sexually active or about the
infection she did not think that she or
her parents could handle the additional
emotional turmoil on top of this new
diagnosis of cancer
so we discreetly treated her sexually
transmitted infection and we also
started appropriate contraception for
her so as it would have been
life-threatening for her if she were to
become pregnant while receiving
chemotherapy and radiation
we maintained a safe space with our
patient and this patient provider
relationship provided her a place to
talk to adults in a way that she had
never had a chance to before
she ended up being the first in her
family to go to college she's actually
thriving
as much as every pediatrician wants to
encourage healthy involvement by parents
and caregivers safe dialogue is not
always possible
however our commitment to our patient
must remain Central to our roles we must
protect this please oppose Senate Bill
253. thank you and I'm happy to answer
any questions I have a question when you
start breaking out specifics
you used numbers of topics like sexually
active sexually transmitted disease
that's not in play here
we're not asking for that in this bill
that is a carve out already federally
when my medical staff read this they I
asked them specify the things that were
this bill to pass you still cannot do
and they mentioned what you mentioned so
I'm not hearing a convincing argument
from you would you care to try to make
the argument using
problems of body and soul that are not
already forbidden here so I'm not an
expert on the semantics of legalese
certainly but I will say that as
pediatricians we want to protect all
spaces of that communication that we
have with our our patients our patients
are truly Central to our jobs and that
involves everything about that patient
so you're saying nothing
should be communicated to this child's
parents is is that what you're saying no
I think you misunderstand so all
pediatricians would love it if all the
patients could communicate openly with
their parents and their caregivers we
actually celebrate that and we would
hope that our families could develop
that kind of communication sometimes
that's not safe for the patient though
and when that's the case then we have to
keep in mind that our patient is our
priority I agree and that sounds like
what's described as isn't it an
articulable fact
if that is the case that is you
articulated it and it can be noted and
therefore
I still haven't heard
anything that convinces me
okay
representative long
thank you Mr chairman thank you for your
testimony
um in your opinion by clear and
convincing evidence the fact that the
teen parents abused each other
in your opinion would that be clear in
convincing evidence to protect again I
am not an expert on the legalese and I
don't understand as it my expertise is
not in understanding the language of
clear and convincing evidence so okay so
you would need to consult with your
certainly with your attorneys to figure
out where you would tie okay and uh
follow up but yeah one one follow-up
um I
what where you articulated is what you
articulated is where you believe that
this
um
that this bill would harm uh has a
potential of harming the child
what you are taking correct to us okay
thank you representative disamoni
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um
on uh line seven of the bill
it says a parent or legal guardian of a
minor child shall be entitled to have
full access to the medical records of
their minor child or award accept
that's on line seven and eight and then
you go down to line 16 and it says
uh where when a health care provider has
determined by clear and convincing
evidence based upon articulable facts
that disclosure of Records to a parent
or legal guardian of a minor child is
likely to result in abuse and neglect
does that statement help you to
understand that if you as a physician
who know your patient feel that it would
create abuse or neglect if you disclosed
and it's written in the law would that
help you to um to agree to this bill
again I'm not an expert in legalese and
I'm always worried when semantics become
involved so I would really need to
consult with some attorneys about that
representative McMahon
thank you Mr chairman Dr uh specific to
semantics when you are carrying out your
your job with your patients
and you and as you just stated that
determining a issue
that could put the child to rest should
the parents know but you also spoke of
medications they're from
with the parents paying the bill would
they not be aware or are they made aware
of the medications that would be
prescribed for their
their child
um that is true unfortunately we don't
have a good protection for insurance to
protect information for our patients
sometimes that is true just a follow-up
follow-up okay well thank you for that
I'll stipulate to that reality but that
being the case does that
allow the parents then to come to you to
say why is this being prescribed and
then what would be the response
the parent actually identifies that on
the bill it's usually my patients with
cancer chemotherapy their bills are 70
pages long so somebody would have to go
through with a fine-tooth cone to
identify that
representative just one more for
clarification Patrick thank you for your
tolerance Mr chairman uh doctor in the
semantics of prescribing uh it's not
quantum physics to look at medications
dealing with
sexual disease
parents would make that's just suggest
they may know what that is
would that then precipitate them to come
to you to say why is this being
prescribed and then what would the
response be in that situation so again
we always try to encourage our teens to
communicate openly with their parents so
there would probably be another
discussion with the child the patient
the Adolescent patient to figure out
what is the best way to disclose the
information but I want the patient to be
responsible and in charge of that
information thank you
representative Raymond thank you Mr
chairman and thank you Dr Kim for taking
time out of your day to drive all the
way down here and share your expertise
with us
my question is about
um kind of normal normal procedures
with adolescents so I think that
um it could be helpful for our committee
if we had a better understanding of
um kind of the developmental differences
between treating say an eight-year-old
and treating a 16 or 17 year old because
your example was an older older child
are there circumstances where
um you would approach that situation
differently as when it comes to talking
to parents or when it comes to making
the decision to have a child disclose to
their parents instead of having the the
pediatrician get in the middle of it uh
just kind of as a general sense children
under I think the age of about 11 or
less their parents have automatic access
to their medical record and
developmentally that seems appropriate
um again there's always exceptions to
the rule that you might have a 10 year
old that is developmentally Advanced for
their age and have some reason to
protect their information as a
pediatrician we would take that into
account
as the child becomes older it's also as
a pediatrician and the American Academy
of Pediatrics we also recognize we need
to teach our adolescents how to take
control of their own health care this is
a safe time to
teach adolescents to
take responsibility for their health and
to learn these steps it takes to be an
adult it's the it's not magic that
sometimes at age 18 you all of a sudden
have all these adult responsibilities we
somebody has to lead them to that
thank you
okay I'm going to remind the committee
we have another committee rolling in at
10 o'clock so be brief and make it a
question
thank you Mr chairman thank you Dr Kim I
just wanted to thank you for your work
because it's really important so thanks
thank you
and thank you Doctor uh chair recognizes
also from DH Matthew is it Hood
yes
morning
we won't call you Jennifer because
you're not in trouble and I'm not a
doctor so you don't have to fair enough
thank you for the record my name is
Matthew Hood I'm the vice president of
government relations at Dartmouth health
um
and it's a pleasure to be here I'm here
to testify in opposition to how this
bill was brought in from the Senate to
your committee uh I'd reiterate
something that Dr Kim said and I love
semantics by the way so I hope to get
into some of the standards that we that
we've talked about so far
um
as Dr Kim indicated we support parental
involvement in the care of their minor
child we encourage that
what we what we have a problem with is
what this bill does
in two ways first we're concerned that
it introduces a new standard that's
inconsistent with both state law
regarding abuse and neglect reporting
and federal HIPAA guidance so I'm going
to start with the state law regarding
abuse and neglect reporting
providers and others are required to
report suspected cases of abuse neglect
if they have a reason to suspect that a
child has been abused
additionally once a report is made dcyf
only needs to show and I think the child
Advocates spoke to this the child
Advocates office spoke to this probable
cause to move forward with its
investigation
the child abuse statute defines probable
causes facts and circumstances based
upon accurate and reliable information
including hearsay that would justify a
reasonable person to believe that a
child
subject to report under this chapter is
abused or neglected
clear and convincing evidence which is
the standard that's introduced in this
bill as it was amended by the Senate is
a much higher standard than reasonable
belief
it is a standard of proof that is
greater than the preponderance of the
evidence which is generally more than 50
percent
um
commonly used to prove civil liability
though less than Beyond A Reasonable
Doubt standard used to use to prove
criminal liability
I looked at jury instructions in
preparation for this testimonial among
the descriptions of clear and convincing
is it's a very demanding standard
um
why is this an issue why is that an
issue it's an issue because it creates a
potential Conflict for reporting
individuals
if a reporter has to if a provider has
to report
if she has reason to suspect abuse she
could yet not meet the clear and
convincing standard and so release
medical records to someone who's seeking
for them under the clear and convincing
that is creates the potential for harm
that we're trying to avoid with the
reasonable belief standard so I just
want to emphasize their different
standards here when the sponsor
introduced the bill
he referenced reasonableness but that's
not accurate this bill is clear and
convincing which goes exactly to
represent representative Raymond's point
that she raised which is it's a
different standard that creates a
conflict
furthermore it's inconsistent as you
noted Mr chairman with Federal HIPAA
guidance which provides that disclosure
of medical records need not be made when
the covered entity has a reasonable
belief that the individual has been or
may be subject to domestic violence
abuse or neglect by such person
or treating such a person as a personal
representative could endanger that
individual so that's my first concern is
different standards that are used here
the second concern in the in the
legislation as amended relates to the
provision about documenting the
determination in the medical record when
suspected abuse or neglect is reported
to dcyf the the report includes quote
the specific information indicating
neglect or the nature and extent of the
child's injuries among other things the
info in the report becomes part of the
case record which is confidential under
the child protection act
if the rationale is already being
reported why is it necessary to include
in the medical record
if the purpose
is to require reporting upon such
determination to deny record access then
you could spell out in that situation a
provider must report because frankly if
a provider is not reporting medical
records then they should be reporting
abuse and neglect to dcyf so I don't
know if that's the intent of the of that
provision of the bill but if it is I
would just specify and clarify that
thank you Mr chairman happy to answer
any questions
I have a question in discussing this
bill with my staff both counseling and
medical they understand
that tender age people need protection
from Bad actor parents they also
understand that parents need protection
from bad acting professionals and both
medical and counseling staff of mine no
people to whom this applies this seems
to me to be leveling the playing field
would you agree with me that there are
Bad actors in counseling and medical
professions I think when we draft
legislation to address Bad actors we we
create problems it's like that bad
um
bad facts make for bad law so I don't
know that I agree with you and I
represent Dartmouth Health that the
providers of Dartmouth Health are Bad
actors
I wouldn't agree with that
none
um
I'll I'll wait to see what Board of
Medicine does as they reform their
reporting
yes representative Perez
thank you for taking me question my
question do you believe that this bill
is necessary
if their parents already have a good
relationship with their child children
do you believe that this bill is really
necessary but this is like
putting
another
step to put a kitchen grains especially
when we're talking about Childs that
have been abused by the parents or
children that they have a mental issues
or mental disabilities
um thank you for the question
representative I
um parents do have access to their
children's medical records today
and if the legislature wants to codify
that wants to specify that I think
that's com but that's completely
reasonable what the issue that I have is
is it as I said creates conflicting
standards potentially for a provider
thank you chairman Pearson thank you for
coming so I'm a little bit confused and
I'm hoping that you could help me out
here
um so what I'm hearing is
there are different levels of
involvement when it comes to children
and suspected abuse so it starts off at
a level that's very we just suspect it
so we could make a report and then
they'll do the investigation and then we
might come to the next level of that
preponderance of evidence or more likely
than not this is happening
um and then we go up the scale so that
would be at this level but as we move up
this scale the next one would be the
clear and concise evidence is am I not
getting that correctly
um preponderance of the evidence and
clear and convincing evidence neither of
which exist with respect today with
respect to child reporting
um
I'm sorry I thought I just had that here
um describing it when I looked it up
um
so I guess maybe clear this so it says
that preponderance of evidence a parent
shall be awarded custody unless dcyf
demonstrates a preponderance of evidence
so we're going back to that idea of
preponderance of evidence and that's
where I'm getting that's my where I'm
getting confused because it seems like
the more information we withhold from
the parents the more we push the parent
out of the child's life am I and again
you said you like semantics so I'm
hoping you can help me understand the
process so what I'm trying to articulate
and I apologize if I'm not doing so
effectively is that it seems to me that
we're this bill would create two
standards
one is reasonableness with respect to if
there's Reasonable Suspicion of abuse a
report is made
this this bill would change that
standard with respect to disclosure of a
Miner's records to its parents to clear
and convincing
which is it's different standard than
reasonable person standards so the
scenario that could result is that
a provider has to make a report
because they suspect they have a
reasonable suspicion that there's abuse
and neglect okay
and yet they could still be required
to disclose those medical the miners
medical records because it doesn't
satisfy a clear and convincing standard
so there's inconsistency between those
two
and that would potentially lead to the
harm that you're trying to avoid
presumably I guess I guess that's where
my confusion then is coming in because
the last follow-up I'm sorry
because the last person who testified
just presented a lot of facts which
would actually be clear and convincing
evidence and a reason to withhold that
information so I guess I'm that's where
I'm mixing up and then so I'm looking at
this as of how
like I said pushing the parent more and
more out of the child's life until you
get to the Beyond A Reasonable Doubt
when the child can actually parents can
actually lose custody so
um I guess that's why I guess I'm seeing
this as it should be somehow steps into
um
the clear and convincing evidence so
we've already passed the I guess that's
what I'm asking you to explain to me is
that
when it comes to
dcyf or whatever
what are the steps that goes through
before the as a parent continues to lose
more and more custody or information
about their children so I would defer to
dcyf with respect to the process after a
hearing is commenced with respect to
termination of parental rights or any of
the things that that you're suggesting
and I think those are standards do
increase
I'm purely focusing on the the medical
record access and comparing it to the
basis that is needed to make a report to
dcyf in the first place and I think I
think I hear what you're saying about a
graduated scale of standards in terms of
proceeding as the parents risk of loss
increases
um but I'm only speaking to that front
part about a report
and the disclosure of medical records
and I think those standards should be
the same I appreciate representative all
that you have a different perspective
with respect to a scale in that space
But for these purposes I think the
standard should be the same
one more follow-up
um just one quick okay I'm just not I
guess I'm just going to go back and ask
again wouldn't you say when we cut the
parents out of giving them the records
and including them in the conversation
aren't we then a step away from
basically taking away custody from their
child aren't we now making them less
involved in the child's life
when when medical records are withheld
the reason for doing so is because
there's a fear of neglect and abuse
that's very subjective I would imagine
would you agree that that would be
subjective if there's we're not based on
facts well I I think as I mentioned the
report to dcyf detailing the Reasonable
Suspicion for abuse includes the facts
and circumstances that led to that
conclusion
sure
and thank you Mr hood for testifying the
chair is now moving on we're going to
call Paula minahan from the hospital
Association and you've got 22 copies of
items and you've asked to speak for
three minutes Mr chair
uh we're moving on
just quick question no not of the last
witness we're moving on to the next one
I'm not asking a question to the witness
I'm asking a question to you go ahead
when we got recognized to ask a question
we asked the first question right
and if we get recognized to us the
following question you have to give us
the right to us another question that
keeps speaking right uh to a point I do
have discretion on that if somebody is
starting to ask a series of questions I
have the right to move on
just asking because I just noticed the
differences thank you
yes good good morning welcome thank you
Mr chairman members of the committee for
the record Paula minnahan Senior vice
president state government relations
with the New Hampshire Hospital
Association representing all our
hospitals we are opposed to Senate Bill
253 relative to parental access to minor
child's medical records as amended by
the Senate
um and I just wanted to just give you
some context and I see representative um
McDonald good morning
um the there was a similar bill in in
representative McDonald's committee
housed in human services
um House Bill 406 we did testify on that
bill in February and due to several
concerns raised during the hearing by
stakeholders and after further
discussions with the sponsor that bill
was retained I mentioned that because
they it um Senate Bill 253 is is similar
in scope I guess I would say
um then when 253 was originally her
heard in Senate Judiciary the vote was
to re-refer the bill however it was
voted to be amended as you see it today
on the floor of the Senate so we um
didn't we had we have a number of
concerns we were not able to testify on
that version that hence why we are here
today I do want to State again as Dar as
Matthew Hood from Dartmouth Hitchcock
said that we are in support of the
general statement of purpose of the bill
and the vast majority of parents
absolutely are acting in their child's
best interest the reason there are laws
protecting the rights of minors and
again this is um age 12 and older to 21.
absolutely are acting in their child's
but um the reason there are rights for
minors are for the exceptions when
parents may not be acting in their
child's best interests so in order to
ensure that the rights of minors are
protected we do not have and that we do
not have conflicting dcyf reporting
requirements and inconsistencies with
federal laws we are asking that the
committee if they choose to ultimately
move this bill forward that you amend
the bill and I did articulate some
suggested amendments um to the bill and
I am happy to articulate those but
they've pretty much have already been
discussed prior we do have concerns with
the clear and convincing evidence again
it um it is setting a separate standard
so we believe it should be replaced with
reasonably believes and you can read our
language
there we did add some language relative
to to HIPAA and I I attached a HIPAA
Privacy Rule q a right from the federal
government so I thought that would be
helpful
um for you and what else
um and then adding another letter when
records or treatment of the minor are
directed by a court of competent
jurisdiction so to add that
and again these are these changes are
intended to ensure Clarity for all
parties and provide consistent
application of the current state and
federal laws and regs that are in place
to protect minor children and we're
happy to work with the committee
um if you are so inclined to draft an
amendment that would include these
suggested changes and happy to answer or
try to answer any questions Miss minahan
if we were to get language that would
help those of us who like the bill and
those of you who don't find that golden
sweet spot in the middle and I were to
convince the speaker to take this bill
out of my committee and give it to
representative chairman McDonald who has
a very similar Bill to this would we all
be happy
some of us would be happy we again we
with these changes we are fine with the
bill I I think and I know representative
Perez I think had the question earlier
why do we need or someone did over here
I'm sorry
um representative representative Perez
um why do we need this bill and I think
we are we had a long discussion
representative kovalt is the sponsor of
um House Bill 406 and he and I have had
many conversations about his bill it
basically and I think Matthew said this
it basically is codifying what is
currently in law but I think as a parent
and I am a parent and a grandparent I
think this is really important to
articulate in the law what their rights
are as a parent of a minor and I think
of my well my children are now
well over there now parents themselves
but when they were 12 I thought would I
really um I didn't realize I didn't have
access to their medical records I I
fortunately
um had great relationships and my my
husband and I with my children they um
so that but now I I've learned
um why we need these laws and of course
I would want their them to have
protection
um and if my daughter was looking as a
16 year old looking to get um birth
control that is really none of my
business
um and I respect the medical
professional to have that relationship
with her so but I think it's really
important as a parent I understand what
your rights are and what your children
your parent your minor children's rights
are because they have rights too so I
think it actually is helpful to put this
into law we just cannot have two
different standards and Matthew being a
lawyer would did a much better job than
I I could to articulate why we would
have those um the concerns with those
separate standards but um that so I'm
happy to work with you and to come up
with an amendment that all stakeholders
can be and the committee be supportive
of I'm ashamed to admit I don't know the
contents of 406 although I should how
close is it to this bill it articulate
it's actually you know a good question
um it it has a lot of the same
um um well as
the the con the the concept is the same
the words are different
um we don't use some of the words
completely clear and convincing it's um
it's it's less it's less legalese it
doesn't have that separate standard the
issue with 406 and I think this is
important because I think Senator Innis
um alluded to this that there are
anecdotes of individuals not having
access to their children's records you
have it's important and this is where
representative kofault um has some
concerns with 406 and so
held it or held it in representative
McDonald's committee there's also a
portal um now we have portals these laws
were written or the you know some of the
medical records laws were written prior
to portals portals are excerpts from the
medical record and I think anyone that
uses one understands you can get your
lab results you can get you can just
have chats with your providers it's it's
a great tool
um but there are certain
um requirements and regulations relative
to portals that are um separate from
access to medical records medical
records are is a full medical record and
the providers are able to separate the
mental health com the pieces of the
medical record that should not be shared
with a with a parent of a minor the
portal is a little bit more nuanced and
more difficult so when people say they
have anecdotal evidence that their
access to the medical records was not
provided the evidence that has been to
me and I have done a lot of research
with representative co-fault on this and
he I think um would would concur
the issues that were raised are about
the portal not about access to medical
records two different things and I just
wanted to to point that out happy to
answer any other questions
I'd like to ask one of Representative
chairman McDonald
um
I don't have HB 406 with me
representative I'm Mr chairman I'm sorry
but go ahead but you do recall roughly
it's on this subject and it was retained
for further work it was and I'm almost
hearing that there's some good intent
behind this bill I mean I am still
concerned about bad professional actors
as I am bad parents sure and I am just
wondering within the committee here if
we may wish to retain this bill and
figure out a way where the two bills
which are so close could be done in
tandem so the language that emerges from
both of them is not contradictory that
would make sense sure
um
representative DeSimone
thank you Mr chairman after you get your
decision on that question I have a
question of the person testifying well
it will it will make a difference in
what happens next could I see a very
informal
bobble head up and down or not on
proceeding with this to exec it either
today or soon versus
retaining it and working on it in tandem
how many would think retaining it and
working on it in tandem I think hands
okay I see
uh oh sure
yeah your seat filling yeah how many
want to get this one done one way or the
other today
okay well it seems that uh a motion to
retain would carry
so with that in mind any questions
addressed to the remaining and present
Witnesses should have that in mind
representative disamoni thank you Mr
chairman
um if you would be so kind to help me
with this
um
a very very very very very long time ago
when I was the mother of a teenager
whose friend went and got
um
some
some medication with a doctor and had a
severe allergic reaction
because the doctor refused to give the
file because during the interview the
kids said
oh my God if my mother finds out about
this she'll kill me
so the doctor refused the child ended up
in intensive care unit due to the
reaction that she had was was that an
appropriate decision when there were no
reports of child abuse before or after
um thank you for the question but I
don't feel
um authorized to answer that question
that that to me is more of a medical
question but it was in the I mean the
health professional had to make a
determination and they wanted to protect
the patient
um and um but that is a very unfortunate
situations for sure
uh Ms minnehan would you believe that by
Vice chair it's just shown me the
language of House Bill 406 and I
discovered two things uh there will be
there is conflicting language and number
two I'm a co-sponsor of 406 and
therefore should have known that
it's been it's been a long session
representative Pearson
um thank you so much thank you
oh sorry you hadn't left and I caught it
thank you representative panic
thank you
thank you Mr chairman for allowing me to
ask this one question
in the case of surgeries
I remember a case when my son had
surgery and he had an allergic reaction
to the anesthesia
his allergist wanted him to
um wanted us to find out what they gave
him so if he ever had
future surgeries not to give him that
medication the hospital would not give
me that information
um
I'm not an abusive parent I didn't fall
into that category
I think maybe the hospital was afraid
there was going to be a lawsuit
so they held back
so are there other reasons why you think
that they would want to hold back
information to parents because of
lawsuits
um
can't answer that question either but
what I can answer is and this came up
during 406
discussions there are consent form again
as a minor the the individual gets has
rights as they turn 12 and consent a
consent form and I have a big file on
406 and happy to pull that out and share
with you but there are protocols that um
to get consent from the minor to release
records to the parents um and that's
probably what was needed
um but I I can't obviously answer
specific questions but we've been
talking about mental health
um
treatment but yes in order to release
medical records there is a consent form
that is required of the minor child to
release it to the parent
thank you for yourself and Emma savini
you have 22 copies to hand out and you
asked for two minutes and you've heard
the motion I'm likely to make in a few
minutes so that may significantly change
your testimony or not
foreign
good morning and thank you for hearing
me for the record my name is Emma savini
I am the children's Behavioral Health
policy coordinator at new Futures new
Futures is a non-profit nonpartisan
organization that Advocates educates and
collaborates for the health and
well-being of all Granite Staters in
light of the motion you are anticipating
making I will be super brief we are here
in opposition to Senate Bill 253 for the
similar reasons that I've been
articulated already
but mostly because I just want to
reiterate confidentiality protects the
health of minors by promoting a youth
driven
and safe environment for children to
receive Mental Health Care our children
are in a mental health crisis as we've
seen from yrbs data and you'll see in my
testimony there is it has been an
increase in depression anxiety and
suicidality amongst our minors so
anything we can do as
um parents
um guidance for minors and you as
legislators can do to promote more
effective and access to mental health
care for our miners the better I think
um
again we think that this bill is very
similar to 406 and if you are able to
retain it in committee work on it and
get some language that helps balance the
rights of those minors to have privacy
in their mental health treatment with
the rights of parents to obviously
parent their children and be effective
parents that would be excellent happy to
take any questions
saying no questions thank you so much
and thank you for your written testimony
and the last card I will
call from now is from Holly Stevens from
Nami and you've got printed out copies
too and you've heard
what's about to transpire so
if I could ask you to be very brief
please thank you
chairman Pearson members of the
committee my name is Holly Stevens I'm
the director of public policy at Nami
New Hampshire Nami New Hampshire is a
Grassroots organization
that whose mission is to improve the
lives of all people impacted by mental
illness and suicide through support
education and advocacy
um on behalf of Nami New Hampshire I am
here today and opposed as the bill came
over from the Senate and I will be brief
you know our main concern is therapy
notes not therapy assessments not
um
treatment plans but the actual therapy
notes themselves is our main concern
knowing that if a child
thinks or is told that the parent will
have access to those therapy records it
may have a chilling effect on
the uh on their willingness to talk with
the therapist and it could really impact
that therapeutic relationship so that is
our main concern we do have we also
testified on House Bill 406 and had some
suggestions also agree that working with
the committee on this we think that we
can come to some sort of an agreement on
both sides to get something moving
forward either this session or next and
with that I will take any questions
seeing none thank you very much thank
you and this concludes the hearing on
House Bill 253 and I now open the exec
session on House Bill 253 and the chair
makes a motion to retain the bill do I
have a second
any discussion
representative Bickford thank you Mr
chair
I hate to be the one to say this but I
I'm very opposed to the bill
um
I think it's a mess
I don't I haven't heard anybody come in
and say this
you know uh say we've had a problem we
need to fix this problem everyone has
come in and said we don't want this bill
except for the sponsor
so I think we should just set it aside
and work on the other bills that we have
which are many
uh in that are retained and there's
already another bill to work on this in
health and human services so I would
prefer to itl the bill thank you
representative Perez
yeah and I will second uh Mr chairman
thank you Mr chairman for allowing me to
speak and I will second
I was thinking out uh with itl the bill
and and I'm sorry that I say I I forgot
to say thank you Mr chairman
we're kind of you know I get it I get it
I'm so sorry listening fine any yes
representative Moulton thank you Mr
chairman I agree with representative
Bickford I think we should I TL the bill
okay anyone else representative desamoni
thank you Mr chair since there is a
house bill 406 I really believe that as
opposed to italing this bill we may want
to retain it so that if
um House Bill 406 needs a little bit of
help this bill is here and we may be
able to combine or use part of this bill
to strengthen House Bill 406. thank you
anyone else
representative Alton thank you Mr
chairman I I just have a question for
representative di Simone
um wouldn't wouldn't Health and Human
Services be able to utilize some of the
language from this bill even if we
didn't retain this bill
as much as I prefer people not to speak
for me I will not speak for Health and
Human Services
the emotion before us is to retain House
Bill 253 moved by the chair and seconded
by the Vice chair and the clerk may call
the roll please
jimin Pearson yes
representative long yes representative
DeSimone
representative Bickford no
representative McDonald
yes
representative McMahon
representative ball yes
representative Panic yes representative
Seidel yes
representative Grossman no
representative Levesque no
representative Petrina will vote Yes
representative Perez no
representative Greg no
representative Moulton no representative
Raymond no
nine to seven to retain
and this conclude
this concludes the exact session on
House Bill 253 the motion passed to
retain the bill we will take a
five-minute break when we will change
some name plates around and start with
the special Commission on Family
Division of the Circuit Court we'll take
a five minute break